r efe y france 24 presentan en primera
plana les proponemos cada semana un
análisis monográfico y en profundidad
sobre un asunto candente de la
actualidad internacional estamos
comenzando el siglo 21 y el cobismo se
lleva a de nuevo reserva se está
evaluando por cuánto dura la inmunidad
con diferentes voces y distintas
perspectivas lo que los gobiernos tienen
que hacer básicamente ahora es tener una
nueva visión del sistema de cuidados no
se pierdan cada semana nuestra ventana
abierta al mundo no se pierdan en
primera plana en primera plana un
programa en colaboración con efe
presentado por carlos herranz